so uh let's just start here at first
okay let's get a strategy I'm seeing
we're working on on uh placement so
pressure is a one strategy but I I tend
not to like it okay um the strategy I
want you to learn is you you you uh keep
the zero pressure so the ike adhesion so
for example uh he's trying to bridge to
get uh his arm and he's trying go do
that escape hold there we go yeah
okay oh you're might be tempted when you
feel him go
up you see okay and what I'm going to do
is just move with him so he goes up and
I move with
him you see that so uh the the first one
he goes and I kind of whoa I'm late you
see I get space so that's negative I'm
too Nega
okay and then the second one he goes to
Bri and I'm trying to hold him and I'm
burning out my biceps and things like
that okay so what I'm going to do
instead as he goes to Bridge and tries
to get the arm I just keep the same
neutral space you see how I did that so
get a good frame that you want okay and
then he's going to try to get get this
arm I just move with it you see that Ah
that's just another iy adhesion just
body to body I'm zero pressure I'm not
pushing into him but I'm not yielding to
it uh on a negative side okay all right
so we'll we'll practice that at first so
he'll do like a really explosive
bridge and you'll just we'll do it one
more
time all right and then we'll let him
get in he got it okay and I'll now fill
the new y
space is around him so he
goes and I F the new Yin space you see
that okay so he doesn't get to use it to
get on the other Escape okay so so you
pay attention what was the Escape that
he did he came here and he went off okay
so we're going to come
back and he goes and he got it but I F
this in space here you see and now he's
flat on his back again okay without me
trying to muscle him okay all right well
technically he isolated that arm and I
want to make sure it's isolated so I'm
going to take advantage and isolate this
arm even more okay this arm so I'm going
to come over the top there's any number
of ways you want to do it you kind hit
him as you're coming around and I'm
going to come under and bring his head
up into that seam you see that and then
to help it trap even more I'll move my
knee under him you see but my goal was
to isolate the arm so what see my pelvis
I'm going to drop it I feel it pressing
on his arm okay and that's what I'm
interested in because this is the arm
that I want to attack so once once he's
there I can always secure over here on
the lat you see that because I'm going
to start attacking this arm so so it's
trapped it's trapped in there because
I'm on his tricep tendon of insertion
see so he tries to pull his arm out
can't pull it out and so I'm going to
now attack it I'm going to drop pressure
more on this arm you see how I did
that try to get your arm out you see
okay I'm just laying on it I still have
this knee over here guarding this hip
for the elbow knee okay then I'll come
up and I'll Attack this arm I'm going to
shove his
elbow
out so my elbow goes
down so he doesn't grab anything on the
way there or he doesn't hook his knee on
the inside crap okay so his arm was
there and pressure p here and down put
my elbow down on the
mat come in at the
armpit okay and now I want to I'm
lifting his uh scapula mechanism off the
mat so I'm going to move up the
circle and I'm still trying to smash
that arm still trying to trap it I move
up to Circle and take my elbow out from
under his scapula
mechanism and my Center Line is now on
his ball and socket joint okay I'm going
to push down on that ball and socket
joint with my chest as I move his hand
stand
up okay got it all right all those
pieces
go
all right
so pump up tight drop my hip okay and he
had his arm here your arm there
okay tries to get his arms
out you me see some of your up like this
get your bottom arm out
okay or it goes into my groin and grabs
my testicles that's not good
okay here checking he can't draw a
weapon can't grab my testicles do you
see that I don't want to give those
things up cuz I don't want him to draw a
weapon okay so as I come around and do
the technique maybe I got to switch
legs you see how I did that okay can you
pull your bottom arm out no no he can't
you see I didn't give it up even though
I moved all right secure my
balance and he's move this arm as you
want there thank you I only let him move
it that way did you see that so for
example try to try to move your
arm that way I don't let him do it so he
goes and I'm letting him
go thank you got it okay get your bottom
arm
out I didn't give it up do you
understand I did not give it up okay uh
motorcycle over the top uh move your
arms how you
want okay uh he go like that right watch
watch what I'm doing move it move it up
and down to try to get it out do you see
do it I'm not trying to hold it he goes
up I go
up you see he can't get out I'm not
trying to pin him he goes no that's not
what I'm doing he
goes got
it do
that okay and pull your bottom arm
out do you understand okay I didn't give
it up so I come
in pop pull your bottom arm
out that I didn't give it up in all that
okay I'm going to start moving out from
under his ball and socket joint and
moving on top of his ball and socket
joint so as I do
it move your bottom arm
out you see I didn't give it up here I
am I'm on the ball and socker Joint
I can push this
down I haven't yet even moved out of the
way I push in it down you see pull your
bottom arm
out got
it I don't want to give up something
okay
so when you're
here and you and Andrew let me get back
in if you guys push down on the Fallen s
it by lifting up pull your bottom arm
out you see that now he gets a weapon
now he grabs my testicles I'm probably
going to have to do something different
now okay I didn't have to give it up I
have to push down on the ball in socket
joint without losing the arm isolation
because he might be armed okay try it
again all right well this we got here
and I got that arm but oh you're saying
oh I can't reach people have big arms
and I can't reach it right I start going
like this and then he's going put that
knee in there and I'm kind of jacked
again okay so I don't want to give up
this space so I can't really get it
happens okay or his arms are so big I
can't get way over there without giv it
up the other arm okay so I'm going to do
a different technique now all right I'm
going to come
under look at this bottom leg here okay
so this bottom leg is going to trap H
that same arm until I get away from it
so I'm going to move again he's going to
go under his head and then I'll step on
my base and now you'll find that's all
the finger distance I needed okay I'm
going now I can pin his hand down I'm
gonna pin his hand
down and I'm gonna start to
rotate put my ear towards that
hip his hand stays down and I start to
rotate I'm lifting the
elbow uh where do you think I am on his
bottom
arm on top of I'm on top of it you see I
didn't have to give it up okay so
again I'm
here oh I can't get I can't get it the
bottom knee is going to come
in to start taking that over that looks
like it's going to go up so I'm going to
go over the top you see over the top
boom tight there separate my
feet keep his hand in place and start
lifting his elbow by rolling
over
okay don't lose the arm try this
variation so I got the movement she
immediately goes to the arm isolation so
here uh this is not going to be enough
I'm going to get out so she got what she
got Slow Down slow down I'll talk you
through it go back where you were she
got what she got on the elbow trying to
get me stuck in there she's going finish
it by bringing this knee under my head
there it is can't get it out now okay
she's going to try for the first
technique don't give it up there's no
need if you didn't have to do anything
don't give it up she goes dude starts
going here and she's just Out Of Reach
you see can't really get it can't touch
so she'll motorcy wait I'll talk you
through hi she'll motorcycle the grip
keep your elbow down right so it can't
open up on her she's going to replace
the arm trap with her bottom leg she
starts to go and I still can't get out
okay she's going to start moving up the
circle without giving up this arm I
still can't get it out bring your left
knee under my head left knee under my
head sorry right knee right knee under
my head don't let it out Bring it more
under my head there
now she steps it's trapped again it's
still trapped she still can't reach it
but I can't get out of it she now steps
over to separate her feet okay separate
your feet and start moving towards my
hip good there she got it she pins this
in
place I wasn't able to move it she's
going to take advantage of that she's
going to pin it there and she's now
going to start rolling her right ear
towards my hip tap tap tap
and she'll get it okay the whole time my
arm is stuck there can't draw a weapon
or anything else
okay uh felt a little weird at the end I
don't know what it looked like on top
was she okay I think the left leg should
have been a little bit more over a
little bit more over yeah it felt a
little high to me okay all right let's
go okay you don't have two hearts you
learned something about
katam the first one is the the ball in
socket has to be stabilized that was in
the first variant the ball in socket has
to be stabilized to such a degree that
uh I can move everything else and then
once I start seeking stabilization on
the ball in socket when I pinned on the
mat that's when you felt the first
technique on the second technique what
you wanted to learn is the wrist and the
elbow uh rotate around each other so I
can either stabilize the wrist and then
rotate the elbow to fect the elbow well
I can also uh stabilize the elbow and
move the wrist around it will still
affect the elbow okay but right now you
have two different techniques so two
different arms so here you are and
you're trying to do K but his shoulder
is not pinned to the ground you see that
so everything kind of looks good but his
shoulder is up you see that I I'll keep
everything the same keep it all the same
and and I'll start to push the shoulder
down you see and is all
ready leave the shoulder up same
movement way more range of motion okay
so first
variation hold around this shoulder has
to be down down down down down is down
do you understand and this knee stops it
from sliding so I am aiming his shoulder
into that corner of my
knee the corner the seam between my knee
and the mat everything is going down
into that and once that's down now I
move his elbow forward towards his ear
so so you can open
it there's where my knee is right there
there's a seam where his shoulder
and the mat and my knee
meet that seam is where I'm driving this
in do you understand once that's dried
in then like the other technique this
elbow goes towards his ear down and the
elbow goes towards his ear and now you
get it okay do it again
one in
to the seam energy is going not there
into the seam you see into that seam
once I have that seam met then I bring
his elbow to this
ear you'll get it if his elbow is up
it's not going to work if your knee is
too far ahead he'll first move to that
area do you get it that slack okay try
it again
so has to go
down down down into the
seam here I'm making it obvious so you
can see the trajectory down okay once
it's down then I push it's down when I
push his
elbow towards his ear this here okay go
push the elbow right that's a that's the
same pinion we're doing earli here okay
oh
look
here that's not
down down on his shoulder there it is
right okay now I
push if I start to
rotate his elbows moving that way you
see don't rotate
down and then towards the Z
okay
next last in the other technique I
stabilize the wrist this time I'm going
to stabilize the elbow so the elbow I'm
going to
stabilize okay and I'm going to attack
the elbow not going to attack the
shoulder I'm going to attack the elbow
so I'm going to stabilize it it's
stabilized Bo like a s kill stab ize it
I could do the same technique so I have
S I could pin and then push could what
I'm going to do this time as I stabilize
it I am going to move the hand around
the elbow do you see that while I'm not
rotating cuz then the elbow's not
stabilized okay so pin pin it in space
and then I start to take his hand around
the
elbow you see that okay so I
got my
technique I go home here and uh any
number of reasons I I have to do this
let's say oh he's really not letting me
Crank that down just like in the other
checking I can't quite get it
stabilize you see stabilize it
and you now have the elbow attack I
couldn't get his shoulder down okay so
here trying to get it trying to get it
all right stabilize it come up and now
start to bring the wrist around the
elbow you going to do
two okay try it go if I can't get his
shoulder down don't try that other the
katama attack the elbow okay go